strikingly beautiful women and daring
writers that's the image the circassians
presented themselves at their folk
celebrations at a folklore evening in a
village in the caucuses in Russia master
of ceremonies as Lanka vahchef is
battling against forgetfulness he says
most Russians no longer know about how
the Czar's conquered his forebears the
Olympics could have been an opportunity
to take an honest look at the past this
is just what we do site internacional
these olympic games are being held in a
place that is very significant and
tragic for our people and to have these
games in sochi without speaking about
these things is just not right no that's
not that you get only about 700,000
circassians still live in Russia today
the Russian army brutally subjugated
Circassia when the Czar's expanded their
empire into the caucuses not far from
where the winter games will be held
thousands of Circassians died in their
last stand against the Russian army most
of those who survived were driven away
across the Black Sea into Turkey we're
at burr chef a Circassian who lives in
Sochi today has called on Russia to
acknowledge that the conquest was
genocide that's why the authorities have
summoned him several times for
preventive talks as they have many who
think like that or any occasion Islam
bottommost position mobile colony we
want respect also for these places there
are countless graves here we wish that
more archaeologists had been engaged
before they built the Olympic structures
new mogul and now it's too late Georgia
about 1,000 Circassians live in the
mountain village of bullsh which may
near saatchi the village school teaches
them the language and culture of the
addy gay ur addy gayer is what the
circassians call themselves in their
native tongue today it is spoken only at
home in the Family in Russia at
air or Circassian is tolerated but not
fostered nice our guests are at a gay
and village is surrounded by Russians
Armenians and people of many other
nationalities Russian is the only
language we have in common but we aren't
going to abandon our traditions in our
language so yeah those are good of
Singapore means to prevent the
traditions from being lost children
start coming to a weekly cultural group
when they are in the first grade the
youngsters hear tales of heroism freedom
and limitless hospitality their parents
want them to be proud of their heritage
the Circassians are considered one of
the oldest nationalities in Europe they
were already living in the caucuses in
classical antiquity when Russia annexed
circassia the people were scattered
throughout the world official Russian
history books have no place for their
tragedy although the circassians still
here learned long ago to consider
themselves part of Russia all the
peoples of the Caucasus are still
stereotyped as being unyielding and
dangerous season time a user's phaistos
killer mr. cash jeans were almost wiped
out in the 19th century and today
they're in danger of being wiped out of
European consciousness and I think
that's almost worse what was thought so
something has to be done against this
something has to be done to commemorate
them and to preserve their culture in
their language and that's very difficult
considering how fragmented their
diaspora is today momentum country as
the villagers of bushwick ish may have
other worries they need better streets
and a new athletic field the council of
elders tell urine apso a delicate to the
duma in Moscow noppe so is a Circassian
who regards the scheduled olympic games
as a good signal thank you so many new
roads train stations and airports have
been built saatchi was always a
beautiful city but now its blossom
a new and even if some Circassian
mountain villages are a bit remote from
it all the children who grew up in this
region will benefit from the game
authorities rose to plan your boo-boos
imaging policy özlem give a chef to had
high hopes that the Olympics would be
advantageous for the circassians but now
he's afraid that Circassian traditions
will be nothing but a folkloristic
backdrop for the Olympic program and if
you sleep even got the Olympic Games are
being held in a place that had a very
negative aura in the 19th century but
that was 150 years ago DS games could
have been used to put old ghosts to rest
to send a signal of peace and
reconciliation like Islamic vahchef many
circassians are disappointed they don't
demand compensation or threaten violence
like some other nationalities in the
caucuses but they want an end to the
silence about the killings and expulsion
'he's the Circassians are proud of their
history
you